joining me now Molly Hemingway
editor-in-chief of the Federalist and
Ben de benich editor at large of The
Spectator both are Fox News contributors
Marty
they act like the Republicans are the
fascists when they are the ones who are
married to these plutocrats who are
exercising it appears to be all the
power within the party regardless of
what the people want right you also hear
the consensus in Washington DC is that
Republicans are very divided they're
actually not divided they're pretty
unified on policy at least among the
voters but you look at the difference
between the Democrat Elite the ruling
regime and their voters they have strong
division the Democrat leaders love
having someone like Joe Biden he's able
to implement all of their goals the
people who run the agencies are getting
to accomplish who are very radical to be
honest they get to implement all of what
they want but they are losing these
voters they're losing not just not just
White
working-class voters but also black
working-class voters and it's a real
opportunity here well kjp was asked
about this problem that the Democrat
voters have with Biden today about his
age and so forth this is what she said
look here's what I know here's what I
can speak to I can speak to that a
president who has wisdom I can speak to
a president who has experience I can
speak to a president who has done a
historic has taken historic action and
has delivered in historic pieces of
legislation and that's important
exploding budget deficit we just learned
about inflations back I just love that
kgp had to read that list oh she did
have to read that it wasn't a very good
list can you remember very good list
look the the real problem that they're
facing right now is that uh Joe Biden's
numbers among uh working-class voters
non-college educated voters are now
looking more and more similar to
Democrat numbers among white
working-class non-college voters and
that's something that's very dangerous
for them and the reason is it hurts them
in particular areas in our political map
in ways that are almost impossible to
recover from if your Coalition becomes a
bunch of white Elites and college kids
then you're not going to be able to have
the kind of Coalition that Joe Biden was
able to form in the past and you're not
going to be able to see the kind of down
ballot results that Democrats need to be
able to hold things like the Senate they
are losing working class Hispanic black
and Asian voters in a way that it should
be stunning to the party Elites and the
New York Times admitting that tells you
how far gone this that was wild and
Molly I think this opens the door in
such a wide way for the Republicans to
walk right through and said this is what
they've done to your cities your schools
your country is this really the horse
that you want to ride in on in 2024 for
another four years
I think it's a it's a huge opening well
to that end in 2020 you had a campaign
where Joe Biden was able to have the
media help him across the Finish Line he
now has a track record and voters are
saying that they're not particularly
pleased with that there was that recent
Wall Street Journal poll that showed
that voters give Trump the Trump
presidency much higher marks in terms of
what was accomplished than the Biden
presidency that they think Trump has a
vision for the future that Biden just
doesn't have and so those policies that
people liked under the Trump
Administration which you see so many
people in so many republican politicians
adopting they do provide a huge
opportunity it's like the Republicans
are sticking with McConnell and the
Republican Elite and the establishment
of the Democrat Party they have a they
have a death grip on Biden I mean they
will not let him go even if he wanted to
quit I think they wouldn't let him quit
the age limits we need term limits we
need new changes we need new leadership
in the country and the Frank and frankly
the people who the problem for the White
House trying to spin this Joe Biden
presidency in the way that they have the
problem John Pierre we get visuals every
single week of how out of it he is how
out of touch he is how he turns into
this sort of wandering uh you know
character as soon as he's done reading
the new statistic I mean statistics
facts about the economy it's a disaster
I mean they said we were coming out of
the the inflation inflation system
working class the most yeah the most
Molly there was a moment with Peter
Ducey and Karen jump here today about
the other issue that we talked about for
two and a half years which was covet
because the first lady the first lady is
tested positive for covid and the
president had pledged that he was always
going to be masking now because
obviously he was in close proximity
check it out
we saw President Biden entering an event
today in a mask here's some of the video
because White House officials tell us
he's going to do that after being
exposed to the coven positive first lady
no mask in this other video as he was
leaving that event not sure why he would
need one to go in that exact way but not
to leave
yeah that was a report not a back and
forth but I mean is that Hillary support
I guess the Medal of Honor recipient the
The Mask he doesn't need the mask but
everybody else I mean this whole thing
this I mean we all know that the smash
thing is a complete joke and yet you're
working signaling you were seeing quite
a few Democrat leaders not just in the
white house but also at the state and
local levels trying to reinstitute mass
mandates even with all of the evidence
we will not come that mask mandates
don't work or other types of shutdowns
this is a this is something that will
not play for Democrats in 2024 the way
it played for them in 20. I'm tired of
sequels both from Hollywood and from our
leadership I'm done with this it's over
we have to move on let's be serious
about this this is a joke I saw two
people in a New England State over the
past weekend biking Outdoors
with the look what looked like the n95
masks they're bringing it back they're
bringing it back I I cleared a wide
berth for that I don't want them veering
toward me in any way Ben and Molly great
to see you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else